All app is almost complete.
As a last feature, let's give our users
a place to record the menu items they've
selected for a specific day.
Here's our app in its current form.
It displays menu items with the title,
image and details link.
We want to add in order tracker that
will track what menu items have been
picked for a specific day and meal.
To keep that modular we will create
this new feature as a component.
We also need a way to let users
choose the item and the meal.
So let's add a drop down with
options for breakfast, lunch, and
dinner and a choose button.
When we create the order
tracker component,
we'll have HTML that will display
the selected menu item, for
a meal but how do we or how does
Ember keep track of this information?
We need some data structure that
will keep the two of these in sync.
This is what a service is for.
An Ember service is an object that
can be used by different parts of
an application.
If Monday is the active day,
then picking strawberry putting for
lunch will update the service.
The order tracker is consuming
the service and will see this change and
update itself.
So this order management
tracking feature is what we want.
Let's build it.